[Musique]
J'espère juste que les gens
quitteront ma page en se sentant un
peu plus normaux et je veux juste
tirer le rideau et dire c'est ce qui se
passe c'est comme ça que
ça se passe
mais si vous si vous voulez  utilisez-le si
vous voulez partir et que vous aimez
cambrer et pop et presser et que vous vous
sentez habilité à le faire comme vous le faites,
dites que vous êtes une maman que
vous connaissez et que vous n'avez pas porté de bikini
dans le vôtre, vous le mettez sur vous
miroir et vous faites ces choses et
vous êtes juste comme
oui, regardez-moi, c'est incroyablement
stimulant,
mais aussi si vous voulez ne pas avoir à vous
soucier de tout cela et laissez simplement
votre cellulite traîner
et être avec vos enfants sur la plage et
sachez que
vous êtes toujours incroyablement digne et
puissant, c'est tout aussi
stimulant,
donc je veux que les femmes aient les outils pour
naviguer dans tout cela
[Musique]
je commençais à me sentir vraiment
déconnecté de tout le travail
et de tout ce que j'ai vu se produire dans
les coulisses  et vous savez
comme si vous preniez une heure pour mettre en place
cette
prise de vue instantanée naturelle et facile vraiment sans effort
alors qu'en réalité cela a pris une heure entière
et il y avait la pose et il y a ceci
et que
tout cela m'a fait penser comme bien peut-être que je
peux être un peu  plus de qui je
suis vraiment en ligne, je peux partager qui je suis en ligne
et dans le processus, espérons-le, aider d'autres
femmes, mais
certainement m'aider moi-même,
ma mère est décédée quand j'avais 19 ans et dans les
années qui ont suivi, j'ai développé
un trouble de l'alimentation et j'ai eu  très
très malade pendant
un certain temps, il y a une telle culture de
l'alimentation désordonnée
et je pense qu'en raison de mon
passé de trouble de l'alimentation, je suis
un peu plus prudent et certainement
plus conscient de cela et de tout ce qui informe
tout ce que je fais parce qu'à la fin
du  jour comme si je pouvais aider une femme
à savoir qu'elle
n'a pas à se sentir coupable de
manger une pizza ou que vous n'avez pas à aller
à la gym
parce que vous avez mangé de la glace ouais allez à la
gym parce que ça vous fait du bien
allez à  la gym parce que tu veux te sentir
fort ne le fais pas à cause de cette
punition comme et si je peux aider une
femme ou une jeune fille à
comprendre cela et à ressentir cela alors
c'est une victoire pour moi
[Musique]
je ne considère pas  moi-même corps positif je
pense que
c'est que ce terme cette catégorie
est très important pour une
communauté incroyablement marginalisée et
s'ils me disent que nous voulons la propriété de
ce terme comme ça c'est leur
droit
donc je suis plus confiant en mon corps amour de soi
euh corps  conscience de ce genre de chose
acceptation du corps
je pense qu'en fin de compte il y a il y a
internet
il y a de la place pour tout le monde mais je pense qu'il y a
une énorme responsabilité pour les gens
comme moi
d'élever ces voix marginalisées
et aussi
de reconnaître tout le privilège que
j'ai je suis comme  proche de la norme actuelle acceptée
que vous pouvez obtenir
et c'est un énorme privilège et cela
me montre jusqu'où nous devons aller
[Musique]
les gens sur Internet sont particulièrement
méchants avec les femmes, donc
c'est assez effrayant de se rendre
aussi vulnérable et d'être comme
hé voici quelque chose que je suis conscient
de ce que tu
penses savoir mais
pour moi la communauté qui a émergé
autour de moi ça me fait me sentir vraiment courageuse
et ça m'inspire tous les jours
et bien sûr il y a de la haine et bien
sûr il y a comme
tu sais  des trolls qui viennent avec
des emojis barf ou quoi que ce soit, mais
je suis prêt à les prendre si cela signifie que
c'est ce qu'il y a de l'autre côté, nous
progressons
mais il y a encore tellement de choses à faire et
encore une fois que cela se retire
comme ça le  la communauté réelle positive pour le corps,
comme
leurs voix, doit encore être entendue,
nous
luttons toujours contre tant de choses différentes comme la
culture de l'alimentation qui
alimentent notre cerveau, alors faisons-nous
des changements
oui oui, mais il y a beaucoup de travail
à faire